[موسيقى]
علش
الكاميراه هو استهداف اسرائيلي
مباشر هكذا وصفته الجزيره وهكذا وصفته
ايضا منظمات
حقوقيه هذا الاستهداف قامت به اسرائيل عبر
اطلاق صاروخين
باتجاه سبعه صحفيين من الجزيره كنت انا
والزميل الي برخيا وايضا كان هناك زملاء
من وكاله الصحافه ال الفرنسيه وم روتو الث
ع من اكتوبر تشرين الاول قرب بلده علم
الشعب في قضاء سور من موقع مكشوف جنوب
لبنان مجموعه من سبع صحفيين من قناه
الجزيره رويترز ووكاله الانباء الفرنسيه
ينقلون الاخبار مرتدين خودات وسترات واقيه
كتبت عليها كلمه صحافه الساعه تشير الى
السادسه ودقيقتين والكاميرات موجهه نحو
الجنوب الغربي باتجاه موقع عسكري
[موسيقى]
اسرائيلي 37 ثانيه هي المده التي فصلت بين
الضربه الاولى التي اودت بحياه الصحفي في
رويترز عصام العبد الله واصابه كريستين
عاصي اصابه بالغه نجم عنها بتر ساقها
والضربه
الثانيه التي استهدفت فريق قناه الجزيره
وادت الى اصابه الزميله المراسله كارمن جو
خضار والزميل المصور ايي براخ التقينا
بكارمن وتواصلنا مع ايلي ليروي لنا تفاصيل
ما حدث يوم الاستهداء 13 اكتوبر كان نهار
جمعه نحن كنا عم نصور بمخيم برج الشمال
بمنطقه سور كنا على كنا على القطاع الغربي
وطلعنا صورنا كان في مسيره بالمخيم ورجعنا
لها نحنا وراجعين كان صار بعد الظهر
تقريبا اشتد القصف صار في كانه فتح جبهه
جديده ب كنا كنا انا وكارمن ان نطلع رساله
من من المنطقه من هناك كان تقريبا شي صارت
شيء عه ونص الساعه وصلنا على الموقع
الموقع كان كثير منيح اي كان كاشف على خط
جبه طويل وبنفس الوقت بعيد عنهم يعني من
تله لتله
و ح يعني التله طلع عليها طله قاحله يعني
حتى ما عليها شجره في عليها بيت وعندها
شويه كم جل ما فيهم شيء عليهم فطلعنا
حطينا تركيه تبتنا وطلعنا اول اول رساله
تبتنا الله كنا نرتدي بطبيعه الحال الخوذ
والستر الواقيه وهذا امر نلتزم به حمايه
لنا اولا وايضا لانها تدلل على اننا
صحفيون سياراتنا مكشوفه مكتوب عليها بريس
واضحه ما في شي مخبى يعني ما في داعي لل
لواحد يشك انه يكون في عننا نشاط عسكري
حوالينا او نحن نكون عسكر او
شي
في
ماسمع صوتك كل الوقت عند الساعه السادسه
ودقيقتين اطلق الصاروخ الاول بلحظه اوف
نير وبسمع بحس بعصف كثير كبير هذا العصف
كان هو اول صاروخ اول صاروخ ستهدف عصام
دغري بخسر عصم في وكريستينا من الاف بصاب
اصابه كبيره باشيا ثم الصاروخ الثاني اطلق
مباشره باتجاه سياره الجزيره كنا انا
والزميل ايي قرب السياره واصب هناك انا
بحس بضربه كثير كبيره ورا دينتي كانه حدا
ضارني بشيء حديثه بو على الارض بطلع بكتفه
ما بلاقي كتفه ما بلاقي ايدي بشوف كتفي
مكسور وبطلع بايدي الثانيه في عندي هذا
الاصبع طاير وعنده راس بس تعملهم ب طبهم
بايديه وببقى بالارض ومش عم بسمع حوالي من
الطوشه كشف تحقيق اجرته وكاله الصحافه
الفرنسيه مع منظمه اير وورز ان قذيفه
المدفعيه من ع0 م اط منل الفاص بين النواق
والرديح سلاح لا تمتك الا اس في
المطقه
large made aluminum was
recovered these features to ammunition
that is available on the market and
these distinct features lead us to one
manufacturer which is systems we also
obtain very crucial video and it shows a
dust and smoke cloud
of journal the first strike can here
clouds act firing of the first shot and
when we run the
video you can see that the second shot
is being fired and there's the round so
if we zoom in on the google maps image
we can see that the shot came from east
southeast here's the journalist on the h
and here the firing position and as you
can see just behind the bl كما نقلنا
لاحقا الى
المستشفى انا اتعافى والحمد لله ال لديه
مسار طويل في
العلاج كان يوما صعبا للغايه لحظات حقيقه
لا يمكن وصفها ان تخسري زميلا
وصديقا بهذه البشاعه بهذه
الصعوبه
ان تتوجهي باتجاه
زميلك تاكدي انه على قيد الحياه ربما هذه
كانت من اصعب اللحظات في حياتي حين
ذهبت لاتاكد ان الي على قيد الحياه والحمد
لله انه كان على قيد الحياه بالوقت لما
كنا بالمستشفى زارونا الي رايتس وش واستي
وجمعيات بقالوا لنا انه بده يعملوا تحقيق
بالموضوع واعطينا شدات نحن
بالموضوع من اسبوع كان
عندهم كان عندهم
صحفي وخلاصه حده
ان تم استهدافنا من جهل اسرائيليه بصواريخ
ما حعمل غير الجيش
الاسرائيلي
من بعد شهرين تقريبا من التحقيق به الهجوم
استنتجت وش ان الضربتين
الاسرائيلين على علم الشعب ب 13 اكتوبر يل
ادوا لمقتل عصام عبد الله واصابه ست
صحفيين اخرين كان هجوم متعمد مفترض على
المدنيين ولذلك جريمه حربنا زملاء في هذه
التط
وايضا جرح عدد اخر رسالتي لهم ان ي يبقوا
ثابتين
اي ساقولها في بالعميه الله يحميهم اي عسى
ان نعود ونستكمل هذه التغطيه معهم القوات
الاسرائيليه تستهدف اي اليه متنقله في
المنطقه وهي غير ابهه ب
ان من تستهدفهم في غالب الاحيان صحفيون
وتحدثنا عن استهداف عدد كبير من الصحفيين
خسرنا زملاء في المهنه جرح عدد
اخر ف والافلات من العقاب الذي تعيشه
اسرائيل منذ عقود اليوم يجعلها بمكان ما
وكانها غير ابهه بهذه القوانين
الدوليه لا
يهمها اي قانون لا يردعها اي رادع فهي
تقوم بهذه الانتهاكات التي تصنف وفق
القوانين الدوليه بان انها جرائم حرب
القانون الدولي الانساني ايضا يضع اطرا
لحروب ولكن اسرائيل ترى ال رادعه لها
تستمر باستهداف الصحفيين والمدنيين على حد
سواء
واليوم الصحفيون الذين يقفون ازاء كل هذه
الصعاب لهم كل التحايا ولهم كل التقدير
على جهودهم ولهم ايضا الشكر لانهم ينقلون
حقيقه صعوبه ما يجري صعوبه هذه الاستهداف
د ف صعوبه هذه الاشتباكات اليوم التحدي
كبير والخطر اكبر ولكن لدينا صحفيون
مسؤولون على قدر هذا الخطر وعلى قدر هذه
المسؤوليه وهم اليوم يكتبون جزءا من
التاريخ الذي سيستك ابناؤنا في وقت لاحق
لانه من خلال كل ما يصور ويكتب وينقل
اليوم نوثق ما يجري وان كنا غير قادرين او
غير و كانت حتى المنظمات الدوليه غير
قادره على محاسبه اسرائيل جراء هذه
الاستهدافات ولكن نحن نراكم ونوثق هذه
الانتهاكات علنا يوما ما نصل الى عداله
عداله تكون منقوصه لان العداله هي ان لا
نخسر كل من نخسرهم
اليوم